كما ظهر على شاشاتنا نذكر بالخبر العاجل
الذي يعرض له قبل قليل مصادر امنيه عراقيه
تقول انه سيارات استهدفت شاحنات عراقيه في
مدينه البوكمال السوريه بعد عبورها الحدود
ظهر اليوم طبعا هذه ثاني مره في خلال 24
الامني الذي يعمل في شرطه الحدود العراقيه
هو يتحدث عن عن ما سمعته وليس عما شاهدته
هو يقول ان المكان الذي وقعت فيه الحادثه
مكان القصف يبعد عن الحدود العراقيه مسافه
تصل الى واحد كيلو متر بمعنى اخر هو يقول
نحن نتحدث بما سمعنا واكثر مما نتحدث مع
شاهدنا على هيئه حال المصادر تقول ان هناك
شاحنات تتالف من 12 ساعه شاحنات كانت قد
عبرت قبل ان حسام ساعه من لحظه وقوع القصف
وقال ان هناك صهريج للوقود كان من بين هذه
الشاحنات لا يعرف على وجه الدقيقه ماذا
كانت تحمل هذه الشاحنات لكنه يقول ان
السماء اصوات انفجارات تلى عبور الشاحنات
كان هناك ثلاث انفجارات
على ما يبدو انها اصابه الشاحنه او تلعب
مع يبدو ان اصابت عدد من الشاحنات هكذا
يتحدث لكن حتى اللحظه لا احد يعرف ما هي
هويه هذه الطائرات التي او ما هو طبيعه
هذا القصف هل هي طائرات مسيره وان كانت
اغلب المؤشرات تقول ان القصف نفذته طائرات
مسيره كما كان يحدث في المرات السابقه
العديده وكما حدث الليله قبل الماضيه ال
سي هذه المعلومات التي نقلها المظهر
الامني قطعناها مع معلومات ايضا او ردتها
وسائل الاعلام مقربه من فصائل المسلحه
عراقيه هي تحدثت بنفس التفاصيل التي تحدث
بها المظهر الامني وقالت ان هناك قصف جويا
لطائرات مسيره هكذا تحدثت وسائل الاعلام
المقربه من فصائل الحشد قالت ان هذا القصف
استهدف رتل شاحنات عراقيه داخل الاراضي
السوريه كان قد عبرته الى الاراضي السوريه
وتقول هذه المصادر ان ان هذه الشاحنات
كانت تحمل مواد غذائيه ومساعدات طبيه الى
طرف السوري لكن هذه تبقى بيانات ومعلومات
او ردتها هذه الوسائل الاعلام العراقي
المقربه من الفصائل المسلحه كما تحدثنا
هذه ليست المره الاولى التي تحدث فيها مثل
هذا القصف هذا القصف هو الثاني خلال اقل
من 24 ثانيه قال 24 ساعه عفوا الليله
الماضيه كان هناك قسما بطائرات مسيره قالت
المصادر انه استهدف راتب من الشاحنات وانه
استهدف التحديدا اربع شاحنات اصابها بشكل
مباشر لكن حتى تلك المصادر التي تحدثت عن
القصد الذي وقع على الامس لم تحدث طبيعه
الخسائر حجم الخسائر تحدد ايضا ما هي
المواد التي كانت تحملها هذه الشاحنات
كانت هناك وتتحدث المصادر الانميه ان هذا
القصف قد يكون اصبح
مشهدا متكررا في العديد من المرات وهو
يعني ليس حادثه غريبه وقعت الليل الماضيه
او هذه ساعه قبل ساعتين من الان المصادر
تقول ان هذا المشهد يتكرر باستمرار شاحنات
عراقيه تعبر من الاراضي السوريه داخل من
الاراضي العراقيه داخل الاراضي السوريه
وما ان تصل الى مكان معين داخل الاراضي
السوريه حتى يتم استهدافه شكرا جزيلا لك
مدير مكتب الجزيره في بغداد وليد ابراهيم